[Music]
welcome
I'm a Hickey Lopez I'm a machine
learning engineer at no Bank and today
I'm going to present FK learn which is
our machine learning library developed
inside new Bank and that we open source
this year in April this year so the idea
is go through a tutorial where I show
how to use FK learn to do like machine
learning build a model evaluator model
but before doing the actual tutorial I
just wanted to do a quick intro showing
like explaining why we decided to build
our own machine learning library instead
of like using other libraries that are
already in the market so to understand
that I want to explain a bit of the
context where FK learn was built so how
new Bank works so for those that don't
know new bank it's a technology company
that provides financial services
it started in Brazil six years ago with
credit card and zero customers and now
we have more than ten million customers
we have multiple financial products like
credit card savings account personal
loans and we are also expanding to other
countries so we have started announced
that you have a product in Argentina and
Mexico - so the company is growing very
fast but at the same time behind this
very fast growth new bank has a very
data-driven mindset so we invest a lot
on data infrastructure to guarantee that
data scientists and business analysts
and everyone that needs to use data to
to their daily jobs has all the tools
and all the data they need to guarantee
that they can take the best decision and
for new bank this is really important
because when you're talking about
financial products every decision has a
huge
both like on the amount of customers and
also in terms of financial impact so we
need to guarantee that we do the best
decisions so in this context we had two
big challenges to face with our machine
learning library with the first one is
the scalability so we needed to
guarantee that we could build like very
fast models so every new product have
every new customer that enters and we
have a lot of new customers we are able
to use machine learning to take
decisions for this customers so we had a
huge need for a library that allow us to
deploy new models new versions very fast
but at the same time we needed to
guarantee that the model that we we were
putting proud proud we were confident
that they will work very well so we
needed a library that provided us
extensive set of validations where we
had we were confident that a new model
that we put in fred fraud
we have no blind spots and have checked
for all the necessary validations before
deciding to take decisions with this
model so it had this two big challenges
and from that we decided that the like
the main pillars of the library would be
the first pillar is models as functions
so we decided to go for a functional
approach and the reason for that
basically to make use of all the
advantages of functional programming so
immutability / functions higher level
functions which guarantees us way more
accessibility when we put a model in
prod
we know that because it's a pure
function the results are always the same
and also it's very easy to put models
and prod because you basically have a
function that you need to pass your
service and needs to the audience to do
it get data and pass through this
function and everything's solved the
second thing is as I said we needed to
have good validation so we build a
library that you can build very
extensible and complex set of
validations for your model and it's very
easy to run
date that and at the same time needs to
be very customizable because we have a
very different set of problems so we
work with credit models but we also have
like NLP models models for customer
service so we have very different
context and each context has a very
different way of validating models so we
needed a library that was very
customizable in the sense and finally of
course we needed something that scale
really fast and that we could like go
from our research or a duper notebook
very fast into production so once the
model is fully validated we needed to
launch very fast and create a new
version very fast so that these were the
pillars that particular in those
building and then came the decision of
like actually open source image and the
reason why we thought made sense to open
source FK learn is because like given
that it has both scalability and very
complex validation and very customizable
validation we felt like it would be
useful both for production scenarios but
also for research so kind of fitted very
well to different types of data science
work so we felt we could contribute a
lot to the community by open source it
and showing the world how to use FK
learn and that's also the reason why we
are here to show a bit how and what are
the advantages of using FK learn ok so
for this tutorial if I will show the
other code here but if you want to
follow via your notebook you can go to
the github SK learn github as it says
open open source project you can go
there you can clone the project to your
machine install it and on the folder FK
learn darkstar's examples you'll find
two notebooks one is the Africa learn
overview data set generation which will
generate the data set that we will use
as a mock for our example here and the
other one is the
killer an overview itself which is the
one that I'll go through in the tail
I'll give some time for the the guys
that are interesting actually cloning
the repple and then I will start while
I'll give that time for you guys I want
to explain very quickly what is this
data set that I will be generating so
basically the idea is to to mark a
problem that would have it new Bank so
you can feel a bit how we use the FK
learn to solve problems at new Bank and
here what I'm what I will try to predict
is how much our customer will spend on
their credit car in the next two months
so I created some like mark features I
simulated some data of like the best
band of the customer the the cell phone
type of this customer has some bureau's
car so it's turning out sources of data
and I marked all these and I created a
complex function that encodes all this
as a target so that's where that's the
data side will be working on on creating
our model okay so now I'll go to the
notebook okay you can see that we've run
a lot in terms of farts and stars since
the this this image the other one is
more of data it has more stars so also I
encourage you and if you like the
presentation should go on github and
give us a star it's very good
to show that our project is growing and
being more relevant we are also we
already reached 1,000 stars which is
pretty relevant for a data science
machine learning library but we always
want to grow more so I basically talked
about these things here so I will jump
to the important a letís and showing a
bit of the data set that I just
mentioned this this doesn't use FK learn
is just
traditional machine learning analysis
pre analysis that you do on your data
before jumping into the ocular but I
will I won't lose too much time here
because I think that different parts
that you guys are not used to is how we
do our models in navigator in itself so
basically this is the data side that
I'll be working on IG is basically
identifier of the customer and I have
multiple data for this customer on every
month that his customer of new bank and
I have like income data I have the phone
type I have some scores I have some
noise also just you check how the model
will deal with noise and I have how much
his pants any then what I want to
produce is the average span of this
customer in the next two months okay
so if I take a look at the features like
nothing very relevant here what I can
see is that income has like a max very
high compared to the 75% higher this
problem this is what I did she try to
simulate like some bug that happens the
customers have infinite income so we
need to treat that on our models just to
show that models are not just feeding
transform we need to think a bit of the
data that we haven't proposed is it a
bit and these are the features that I'll
be working with as I said some randomly
generated features looking at the
missing I have some missing that bureaus
cars the idea of having missings here is
to simulate a problem that you have when
communicating with external data sources
sometimes they might not have this
customer on their base or it's just a
problem with like it be requests or
something like that so you can have lack
of data for these cases so I'm trying to
simulate that here and the features as I
said are like normal distributions other
types of distributions and in the end
they combine them to create a ice-pan
formula here and I use this mouse band
like the next Shuman
spend as a target for my model okay
plotting here the amount of customers
so the amount my my base is growing very
fast
this is interesting because real-life
problems you always have the temporal
challenge of understanding how things
are changing over time and we will also
show how we can validate this type of
problems or these types of behaviors we
ffk learn with ease quickly showing the
distribution here of the features won't
lose much time here the targets just a
sanity check if you don't have missing
at the targets we only have missing at
the last two months and that's because
like we are censored in the sense that
we don't know how much this customers
will spend on the next two months
because this two months didn't happen
yet so we can't use this two months to
train our model we can only train until
that point and as you can see that the
average spend is dropping over time we
can also like try to understand how this
will affect the model performance later
so now we go into the fun part which is
actually starting to use FK learn so the
first thing every data science does when
at least you should when building on
your model is to split your data into
training tests on on real-life scenarios
we pretty much never would use something
like a random split because we want to
like add semantics of meaning to our
split so we can represent better what
happens in real life so in this case
here I'll be splitting both in time so
my training data will always be before
the validation and I will also split on
what we call spatial splitting which is
basically I will train on a set of
customers and validate on a different
customer even though they have like
multiple months where this customer is
here just to guarantee that I'm not
fitting to this population and that the
model would generalize well to different
customers that will come every month
that's really important because when you
put in production if you're like a
company like new bank that's growing
very fast we'll have a completely
different set of customers that will be
scoring so we need to guarantee that
your mother is not overfitting on
specific population so what it looks
like is something like this so I have a
training set which has a subset of our
customers and I also splits own time so
I end up with four data sets one is the
training and all other are different
types of validation and so how we do
that with FK learn it's very simple we
have a space/time split data set
function and as you can see here
everything will be a function it's very
we won't find classes here so because
it's functional everything it's a pure
function that receives parameters and
returns some variables usually we work
with pandas data frames so that's the
way of communicating with data and so
here I'm calling this basically data set
and I'm passing my original data frame
which I read before and I'm passing like
this this period that I want to split my
data so like the train is starting here
is ending here which is like from
2017-2018 I have some period for
validation and to October and that's
basically it so I'm calling this
function and it returning me for data
sets as I'm showing here okay now we
want to to train our model so that's the
first step we engage on is like training
the model but as I said before we've
seen some things on the data that we
need to check off before actually doing
some regression on the model so in this
case here we'll probably want to cap the
feature like the income
so that's a very strange value on some
cases so we probably want you cap to
avoid the fact of outliers on your model
you also want to encode the categorical
feature so we have some phone data and
you want to create categories from that
you have some missing data for the
bureau's car so you want to do some
Street strategy for missing or not
depending on the model that you're
building and you want to finally train
your model so how this works on a scalar
so it's something similar to what you
would do on a scalar and fit transform
but in a functional way which guarantees
that like the Frenchman that will return
is pure if if you ever worked with sq
learn you might find yourself like
declaring a model fitting it transfer me
then you fit again and you don't know
like what results I expect from this
transform because the class has been
changed a lot of times and you have what
we call eye state so the order that you
run your notebook influences that the
result of your model transform that what
we want to avoid with a few learn
because if you train a model and it
depends on the state of the notebook is
very hard to put that modeling
production because you have to guarantee
that this state of the function is
correct when you're dealing with
vascular and you don't need that because
a function that gives you a result will
never give you a different result for
the same data
it doesn't depend on the state of this
this notebook
so you can put in prod on a completely
different environment and we still give
you the same results and how that works
so on training time we will have the
scenario on the left here which I I
create a pipeline and I give my training
data and will pass choose to these
functions and each function will learn
something so like the if it's a labeling
holder it will learn the labels and this
translation of the labels and we will
also put a function which is the orange
part of this so the learning happens on
the blue part and
the function that returns is the orange
parts so when I create a pipeline I
basically go through all this blue stuff
and return what we see on the right
which is only the orange functions so
when I'm scoring the data which is the
equivalent of the transformed part of SK
learn what I'll be doing is basically
applying these functions to the data I
remove the blue part because I'm not
learning anything new when scoring the
data I'm just in transforming what I
have already so how that works on FK
learn here is a just a quick explanation
of functional programming technology
it's basically if you have a function
that depends on like a data set and a
lot of parameters when you're working
with functional you can create what we
call partial function by defining the
parameters when int you used to have a
function that depends on the data set so
kind of predefined two of the parameters
but it still have partial function
that's a important concept that we'll
use a lot here so let's see how I would
build this pipeline here and the way I
would do is basically creating these
partial functions for each step of my
model so let's say I need to cap the
feature the income feature on arbitrary
value of to 2000 K here so the way I do
this is create a capper where I define
the column that I want to cap and I
define watches the cap for this viscom
perfectly let's see if I can show you
the code of the capper just you so you
can understand better the
let me see where's transformation okay
so if you look at the code of the capper
and compared to the what I have here I
defined the value of columns to cap and
pre-computer caps but I didn't define
the data frame that this will be applied
on so here I have like a parameter that
I didn't define yet so this is a partial
function so here the color okay yeah I
need to increase the size here
it's better
no problem I have hard time zooming on
PyCharm but yes sorry
so I'll go through this again on the
other code I defined the variables
column shoe cap and a column the
variable precomputed caps but I didn't
define which data frame dues will be
applied on and why I did this way
because this way I create a generic cap
or function that can be applied to any
data frame like any data frame that I
apply this it will apply this
transformation so let's see how that
evolves in my code and I do that for all
the other pressure function so the label
categorize err I do the same thing I
just defined the columns to categorize
but I don't define the data frame that
will be applied on the same further in
puter
which fuels the missing values i only
defined the columns to input and they
put input strategy i don't define the
data frame and finally the add GBM
regression learner so i'm here i'm using
a light GBM model i don't define the
data frame that this will be applied on
so what's happening here is that I'm
creating this box of encoder missing
pepper and regressor but I'm not
defining watches the green data then I'm
going to pass to these functions and
that's very useful because if I change
my green data I have another training
data I don't need to redefine all this
stuff again I don't have a stage I have
a set of functions that I can pass
anything to it and we will return a
different training model so continuing
here I create a pipeline that exactly
defines that box and the link between
the functions and then I can finally
generate this training function which I
can apply to any data set here I'm a
praying applying to the training set
that I created before but it could be
any data set that I wanted and what this
returns me is a predict function which
is basically
the right box here this one that's the
prediction function it's like the same
functions the same pipeline but already
learned the the parameters of the model
the regressor the crapper and everything
it also returns the train set but
transformed with the predictions so
basically already does a Fitch transform
on the training data not very useful
like to look at predictions but it's
useful to test if you're how our model
is overfitting for instance you can
compute performance from this data and
return returns a set of logs which is
basically metadata about the
transformations that you did it this is
very important for multiple reasons like
if you want to feature importance it
will be on the logs but also if you want
like if you deploy your model you can
always apply together with the Train
logs so have metadata of when I train
this model how many many data points I
use to train the model so this is very
useful for us and that's the result of
like the feature in transform this is
the data set it has a new column which
is the prediction column but like it's
not very useful if I look at the train
logs and I access the regressor learner
I can access like the future importance
of this model from here and I can plot
this data frame that has the feature in
partners ok so like so far the the only
advantage of having a scale learning is
like building this pipeline TVs but I
will show how how good having functions
as models is because if you remember I
have three validation sets and if I had
like as he learned I would need to apply
like the transformation a lot of times
but as I said you don't have guarantees
that the transformation is stateless so
every time you apply the transformation
I have to check if the model is the same
here because I generated the predict
function I'm pretty sure that the model
is stateless will give out the same
reason
so I can apply the predicts function
show all the validation sets so I had
three validation sets I can apply this
same predict function to all of them and
we return me a different data set for
each one of them with the predictions
for this discussed immers so if I take a
look at one specific day of them which
is both out of time and space I have
like predictions for this customers okay
so I have my model now the next step is
of course validating the model so how
you validate models inside a feeler and
the cool thing is if you think about
like what probably we want to validate
the first validation step it's a good
regression model so we probably want to
look at r-squared and maybe some
experiment correlations and things like
that but in the end you want to validate
all these data sets the same way so why
not do abstraction that looked like this
so I create a valuation function that is
not applied to any data set directly it
depends on the data set that we will be
using but you know always compute the
r-squared and the Spearman correlation
for all these data sets so then I can
pipe all the data sets that are
generated you have the performance for
them how you do that with F key learn so
basically in part the evaluators and you
define like what's the prediction column
what's the targets column for them and
you create a combined evaluator that has
both the r-squared and this pyramid
evaluator and then you can like you
create this eval function which can be
used several times to compute the
performance on all the data sets that
you had previously okay and what this
returns you a very like dictionary with
performance but data science don't like
dictionary we like data frames at least
I prefer data frames and dictionaries
and these dictionaries can get very busy
so it's hard to to handle them that's
why we have like the extractors and the
extractors is a very good way of
back to data fringe from performance
logs how you do that you basically like
you have r-squared evaluator and it's
premium valuator you create a combined
evaluator that has both structures and
you apply them to the log very simply
like this return you a data frame for
each one here i'm concatenating all just
to show what's happening so right now
it's basically I did all the steps of
training a simple model and I want to go
back a bit so let's say like the
performance is really good you're
satisfied with your model you want to
put in production how would you do that
it's actually really simple all you need
to do is get your predict function this
one and pìkô it in it's a production
model so for us this was like a pretty
huge and important aspect of a scaler
that we have like trust ability that our
models are immutable and we can very
easily put a function in production it's
already scoring a new model so it's very
easy to do new versions or new models by
having like a very standard way of the
pie models like this okay but the other
part of FK learn is complex validation
right so that's the way we did
scalability but we need we still need to
validate because here I only have like a
few set of metrics and things can get
way more complex so if you go to like a
business decision with your like my
r-squared is 0.63 I want to ship this
model you might be faced with a lot of
questions like how is the model
performing over time how is the model
performing on the sub population what
would happen with the model performance
if I had more data is those data helping
or making her mother worse so we might
be faced with a lot of questions and
what we found by experience in your bank
is that a lot of these questions are the
same for a lot of
models so what we invested a lot was
creating a easy way to answer most of
these questions using a scaler okay and
so here I'll give some examples on how
we answer some of these questions and
how easy is to use the abstractions that
we define before to validate these
things so the first validation that I
will go through is like what would
happen if I had more data which is
usually called as spatial learning curve
so if we actually had more data to train
our model we would simply train the
model and see if the model is performing
better but the thing is you don't have
it you need to simulate what would
happen and a good way to simulate what
would happen with your model if you had
more data is doing several trainings
with like gradually more data from your
training set and validate this model on
a fixed amount of data and see how the
performance of your model is improving
so something like that I would train
model one with very small amount of data
and validate then I trained model true
with Margera and validate and this would
give me like a curve of how my model is
improving with more data right and of
course I can like abstract what would
happen with even more data than what I
have today so how in a more general
sense what I'm doing here is I'm
splitting my data into subsets of
trainings and tests so train one is a
very small training with large test
train to is a slightly bigger training
set with the same test set and so on so
forth so it's something like that I
split into multiple combinations of
training tests I train a model on this
train I validate the test and I get
results for all this so this first train
here would be the Train one with very
small data and if I go through this flow
I get the performance of train one the
one would be trained to with slightly
more data if I go to this floor I get a
performance of trying to and then I can
evaluate how my model is getting better
with data but when you look at this and
you look at the training function what
has changed from the training function
that I defined before nothing actually
like it's the same pipeline that are
going to apply to different sets of data
and what what has changed from my
evaluation function nothing because I
still want to infer what's the r-squared
and the Spearman correlation of this
model so basically what I need to define
is a a splitting function that will
create this fold of training tasks for
me and that's the importance for the
spatial learning curves than with the
spatial learning curve splitter surprise
and I pass here that the space column is
daiji the time column is the mouth and I
want to train my model with like 1% of
all the training data 20% of 10% sir 10%
of all the training data trend percent
of all the training data and so on so
far and then I pass through this like
abstraction which is exactly this flow
here but written on code so it receives
a training set it applies this splitting
it supplies the training it applies the
evaluation and gives me all the logs
that I need so after doing this
validator what I get is like a huge log
of all the trainings and all the
validations that I have from this
process and as I said like distraction
is still the same because I'm I still
want to get the R squared and the
Spearman correlation out of this model
so if I stretch that using the same
extractor that I define before I get a
data frame that looked like this so I
have the matrix R squared and spearmint
and I have like the Train size and
what's the percentage of this of the
total is de straining so I have like
different percentages and if
metrics for its percentage so I can very
easily plot something that looks like
this so there are squared per Pharma's
given the amount of data that I'm using
for training and here's like the first
example of how FK learned functions are
useful for you to like reuse the same
functions that we would find before so
you don't need to worry if your
validation is actually running the same
model that you had on the first step
because you are using the same function
and it's pure so you always will the
same results so that's how we do it now
go to one more example
which is come now the other question
that we had there is like how is your
model performing over time so if you
think about this question you don't
actually need to retrain your model you
just need to evaluate your model on
subpopulations one for each month so
instead of going through all this flow
what I need to do is like define
subpopulations and use the same
evaluation function on the these
different subpopulations right so here
I'm defining AI splits evaluator which
takes the evaluation function original
but I came to find like a splitting
column of mouse and watched values I
want to split on so I want to evaluate
this model from almonds from 0 to 25 so
all the full two years of data that I
have and I also define an extractor
which will from the logs is track the
performance into a data frame in the
same way that it did for a simple
validation so now I can call this
function on my holdout data which has
the predictions and I can apply the
extractor on the logs that I generated
and I have a data frame that looks like
this
so for each month it computes me the
performance of the model in the
beginning it should be really noisy
because you don't have many customers on
the first maps and should stabilize
later or the performance might get worse
depending if your model is like losing
performance over time so let's see not
sure how it's looking here so it seems
like your model is not getting worse is
like has some noise in the beginning
because of few customers but it's kind
of stable over the same values so what
I'm showing here is that it's very easy
to go from your evaluation a simple
evaluation from more complex one that
computes the evaluation on different
sets of people and on complex context
you might have like very different
subsets and complex subsets so in this
we might want to evaluate like how the
performance is different from iPhone
users and Android users because I have
this feature is very used to create a
evaluator on top of that and now you can
combine evaluator so I could have like
Android versus iPhone but I could also
have Android versus iPhone by mouth by
something else so it's very easy to
create complex trees of validation okay
and then my final example here is like
what if I want to combine both so what
if I want to check the impact of having
more data on a monthly basis so now I
want to combine my spatial learning
curve with the monthly performance
evaluator here as I said before you
already have your training function you
already have your evaluator function
that you've just created a both you
already have your split function that
does your folds given your original data
so your task is as simple as calling the
parallel validator again but instead of
using the normal evaluator you pass the
mouse evaluator function so you didn't
create any new code and you are doing a
very different evaluation and comparison
and there's a huge value on that
because you lose very little time to
check different subsets different
validations different assumptions and
you can guarantee that your model has
very small blind spots or no blind spots
so when I create this further validator
I already receive a log with the
validation and if I use the same
extractor that I had before I already
have a data frame here so let's take a
look of what this data frame showing me
so it has the R square that experiment
as we are now used to it has like the
mouth which is evaluating so I'm
evaluating the amount 15 among 16 the
month 17 but it also has the percentage
of the training data
was used for this month so as you can
see I have the month 15 two times here
or three times or Mar and for each of
these times I have a different
percentage of the training data so I'm
using more and more data for this dis
evaluation and if I plot this again what
look likes is something like this so for
each month with Mart data how my
performance is very as expected like the
adding more data has a symmetric shape
and regarding almonds so the model is
kind of learning and the same rate for
all the other months but you can also
see like that the month 15 performs
worse than the other months I don't have
like explanation for this simulated data
why did this happen
but it's just a way of showing the types
of validation that you can do and how
easily you can check for different
scenarios and not rely on unlike single
R squared or AUC metric to deploy your
model right and what else do we have on
a scaler basically this was the example
that I wanted to bring you guys but what
else could we do with a scaler
so we have several other learning curves
so here I showed only the spatial
learning curve but as I said there are
many questions that you can ask
like what's the the performance of my
model over time so you could do a
validation that gradually makes your
holdout further further away from your
training and computes the metric for
that so you could answer like if your
portfolio of your data is changing a lot
you would see a drop in performance and
her holdout there's several other
learning curves that we could use and we
have all of them implemented here we
have other algorithms so let's say you
want to do X abuse or linear regression
or other types of models we'll have all
of them there
and we have other interfaces for common
data science tasks for instance let's
say you want to do a feature selection
if you think about feature selection is
not much difference from my learning
curve so basically the training function
would be the same as the training
function before but every every
iteration you take a feature away from
your model the valuation would be the
same because you want to evaluate the
same metric when you remove features
from your model and the extractor will
be the same so calling a feature
selection would be a feature selection
algorithm would be as simple as calling
like a parallel validator and will give
you all the results for all the subsets
of features that you want to select and
parameter tuning is the same like
basically you're doing several training
steps and validation but changing your
parameters from your model so all of
that comes very easy once you define
like your training function or
evaluation function that's the the value
of XK learned and if you want to learn
more about SK learn we have a blog post
about how was the process of doing FK
learn and we'll have actually two blog
posts one is like the introduction to FK
learn and the second one is a more
in-depth blog post about how to validate
models and how we build all these things
that I showed you here and we also have
documentation from for all the functions
that we have on a scaler and I think
that's it so now I can open to questions
so if you have questions about the
library or new bank or anything I just
wanted to make a quick note that we have
some people from new bank here want to
raise your hands so after the
presentation we will be at the meetings
and the other presentations and tomorrow
and Sunday as well so if you have any
questions that you want to do about a
scalar
no bank or anything that we could answer
we will be around so please ask us and
tomorrow we'll have also a stand so it's
easier to find us tomorrow but feel free
to ask anything
Thanks
[Applause]
hello thanks for the presentation I have
a question about how do you possess this
function and does it cut down dependency
in production or things like that how do
i parse the function how do you persist
this function for production izing okay
so of course like the way you put in
production things depend a lot on your
infrastructure so we have an
infrastructure that's very well built
around the FDA learn so for us put your
modern productions as simple as
serializing this FK learning predicts
function as I said and just on
serializing it's on the production
environment and it's pretty safe in the
sense that the function is immutable so
you don't need to worry about too much
about the environments that you're
unsterilized in your function it should
work really well of course like real
time models and batch models have very
different ways because you need to set
up by image points so you can like give
all your features through your model or
something like that and this varies but
the model itself given like the data
it's pretty much a function that you
want sterilized in production thank you
a nice presentation so my question is so
what is the back end of f killer I mean
so I'm wondering does it call
scikit-learn API or yes basically we
didn't bring Clemente all the algorithms
like logistic regression random forests
or anything we used like the most
traditional libraries so behind FK learn
we have a scaler and we have extra boost
we have like GBM all the implementation
the most common implementations of this
algorithms we basically do a wrapper on
top of that so it's functional and your
guarantee that you can't like actually
change the model class for instance so I
can show you very quickly
need to zoom again so if you go further
like GBM function
you're basically part the the library
itself and inside here we'll use the
signature that the light GBM uses which
is not functional but when we return the
predict function would be this P and
it's immutable and it already has the
objects inside it on its closure so you
can't actually change that it's
immutable in that sense but yeah we
didn't represent any already thank you
maybe I missed it but in this library do
you have the capability to work with
neural networks not yet so that's one of
the main things that we want to
understand how we would add neural
networks or any other libraries that
already has this functionalities to a
scaler like the reason that we open
sourced is both that we want to share
like the work we did with the community
but we are really open to contributions
and people like try to understand how we
could improve the library by adding new
functionalities in this this environment
so no we don't have anything for a
neural nets yet
[Music]